you can see right behind me in the
distance there's smoke billowing in the
air those are protesters that have set
tires on fire and there's demonstrations
from supporters of Usman sanco all
across the capital despite heavy
security presence I mean I haven't seen
so much Security on the streets of this
Capital since there were other
demonstrations when Usman sonko came to
court in March 2021. now Usman sanco
made his way towards the tribunal we
followed him there were thousands of
people following him as he was making
his way to the courtroom and then
suddenly the police came in took him out
of the of his vehicle and brought him to
court it's a defamation case and if he
gets sentenced then he will not be able
to run in the presidential elections
that are supposed to take place in
February 2024. the fear is that
President monkey Sal could run for a
third mandate why well because during
his time in office he tweaked the
Constitution he reduced the the years
that the president can stay in office
from seven to five years but he's also
allowed himself the ability to run a
third mandate so a lot of people that
you're seeing on the streets and we're
seeing a lot of young people taking to
the streets is less in support of Usman
Sanko but they say it's about defending
their democracy in the institutions the
Democratic institutions here